[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga around
the world one person is forcibly
displaced nearly every two seconds
that's the highest level of displacement
on record it amounts to over 70 million
people trying to flee to safety often
risking their lives in the Mediterranean
600 migrants drowned in the first half
of this year alone after a two-week
standoff with Italian authorities who
were blocking access to ports a German
rescue ship last week forced its way
into the port of La Medusa leaning to
the prompt arrest of a captain migrants
seeking entry to the US also faced
dangers including cramped and unhygienic
conditions in holding caps along the
southern border with Mexico trapped
refugees rescue forbidden that's our
title this week on quadriga
and here are our guests Anna Maria
Alvarez from Costa Rica is a refugee
activist and founder of the migration
hub she says we don't combat irregular
migrants by letting them die while
crossing borders we do it by offering
safe and regulated pathways and fair
migratory policies both for the country
and for those migrating Siouxland said
Osho works at the Humboldt University
and she's an expert on migration issues
she says humanitarian rhetoric alone
doesn't make humanitarian policy US and
EU migration policies are more similar
than we may think and it's a pleasure to
welcome multi-lane name back to the
program he works for the daily newspaper
dear takács beagle and he says we will
only achieve a humane European refugee
policy if a EU citizens assent
Europe has had to tighten its borders in
order to prevent right-wing populist
from gaining the upper hand so sueleen
let me start out by asking you about the
numbers that we're seeing as I mentioned
this is in fact the biggest wave of
refugees worldwide on record since the
second world war why is that and must we
expect this trend in fact to continue
rising it's in
the case that the refugee influx to
Europe has been unprecedented since
World War two but the reasons are very
diverse we see people fleeing from war
but also people searching for
opportunities in Europe
so there's on the one hand the
intensification of war in conflict in
the Middle East and hardships in South
America that lead to large movements of
people but there's also economic
developments in Africa that lead to an
increase in the number of migrants
arriving from there and also crossing
the Mediterranean through Libya
annamaria those who advocate tighter
borders often see refugees as people who
are making an economic choice basically
looking for a better life those who
advocate doing more to open borders to
receive them typically see refugees as
victims for example of conflict of
environmental disaster and and so on
we've just heard it's a lot more
complicated than that what does that
mean for policy well actually just said
it a game correctly right I mean we have
to make a distinction between who's a
refugee and who's an asylum seeker and
who's actually looking for a pre-owned
aa Mical opportunities right so we have
to distinguish that in the first place
and yes of course especially when we
talk about what's happening in the
Mediterranean and people seem out
especially from Libya these days I mean
just I guess was just a writer the
strike happened and killed 40 40 people
you know in a migrant camp in Libya so
so of course it's is unjust
right so what it means for policy means
that many countries have sign up and has
committed to this Global Compact
recently which is basically to save
warrant and try to try to prevent these
people from dying from the sea and
actually creating more safe pathways for
migrants to come obviously countries
like Italy Austria Australian United
States were the ones who sign up is the
Global Compact for example a a a
solution of course not but it's a
commitment from these companies to
strengthen and actually
basically it'll take care of the
pathways of migrants and when they're
migrating both as you pointed out with
your opening statement anti-migrant
sentiment essentially xenophobia often
has become a driving force for
right-wing populism in europe but if you
look at this to statistics rich Europe
has taken in only 16% of the total
number of people who are fleeing it's
actually poor African and Middle Eastern
countries that have taken in the vast
bulk of migrants worldwide
is that fair it might not be fair and I
mean you're completely correct I mean
the Syrian migrants from Syria they
basically are in Turkey in Jordan and in
Lebanon I think six millions of us seven
millions of them on of these three
countries combined so if you compare to
these three countries Europe in its as a
bloc has not taken in a lot but and
there is a but to it the but is you have
to reconcile the humanitarian imperative
to help those people with the acceptance
of the local people and it seems to be
lacking a huge part of acceptance after
as you mentioned in your question in the
first part of your question and you
witness as a consequence of this the
rise of a lot of basically right-wing
populism in Europe that that is the
consequence of an open border policy so
it's not a question of fairness it's
question of how many could be reconciled
with the societies in Asian states in
Europe Selina as you implied in your
opening statement there is a lot of
humanitarian rhetoric in Europe but you
were essentially saying that the
practice is something else the fact is
there is a strong body of migration law
in place we have rules and systems and
processes for how to deal with the flow
of migrants but obviously that system is
broken or we wouldn't be having this
conversation yeah so the body of law
does not reflect the political reality
and this is something that I want to
come back to which is
making this connection between the
influx of refugees and right-wing
populism is not that clear right the
countries that are most opposed to it in
Europe namely Poland and Hungary there's
a those are the countries that had the
least influx of refugees in Europe right
so they they base their anti refugee
rhetoric on sort of a threat perception
around refugees right and this is this
is the thing that we have to tackle I
don't think people are opposed to the
humanitarian idea of taking in refugees
I think what they are afraid of is the
unregulated uncontrolled way that
refugees are entering so by saying that
we should not save people from the
Mediterranean because that will fuel
right-wing support I don't think is the
real narrative the narrative is to bring
people over to Europe safely and have
them vetted have them background checked
and be humanitarian also in the size of
migrants that we want to bring in not
just saying we just shut it off in order
to you know drain the the right-wing
rhetoric that's not what we should do I
think this is also not the the solution
to this rhetoric because it is based on
a threat perception rather than on
reality in my opinion I want to come
back to you multi I know you wanted to
respond to that but let's just take a
brief look at the situation in the
Mediterra Mediterranean and particularly
a look at just how dysfunctional the
practice there has become it was
illustrated in the past few weeks when
we saw a crisis that essentially pitted
the captain of a German refugee ship
against Italy's populist leader Italy's
interior minister Matteo salvini
nicknamed Capitano he owes this not to
his love of the sea but to his strict
policy on refugees
she on the other hand is a real captain
German refugee aid worker Kahala Decatur
many consider her a hero two weeks ago
she took fifty three refugees aboard the
Seawatch three and brought them to Italy
despite Sall Viennese entry ban she
finally decided on the Saturday night to
enter the port on a small Italian island
of Lampedusa
we declared a state of necessity because
the psychological situation and the
humanitarian condition has been
worsening so much that I cannot
guarantee the safety of the rescued
people
the captain was under arrest for several
days for entering the fort illegally and
because he watched three collided with a
border patrol boat salvini thinks she
should spend years behind bars he says
it was a criminal warlike act this
hikita a hero or a criminal so matter
who's right the captain mr. Kator
or so many the captain is right I mean
you have to save lives
point there's no discussion about it and
there's no butter there's nothing else
that's a humanitarian imperative you
cannot let people die who are in need so
there's nothing to add for it having
said that there is a dilemma we are
facing the dilemma is you don't want to
encourage people to go on a on a on an
adventurous trip that might kill you so
by saving lives go sometimes you're
sending messages to to people who are
coming so there's a dilemma you cannot
escape just easily and saying I want to
blend out the consequences of it you
have to save life that there is no but
to it but there is something that you're
encouraging people to go on this I want
to take that point to the other guests
in just a moment let me just ask you one
other thing that goes back to your
opening statement and the idea that we
may have to tighten borders in order to
prevent right-wing populist from gaining
the upper hand in fact don't actions
like Salvi knees tightening the borders
of Italy in many ways feed the kind of
xenophobia that sueleen just described
rather than actually reducing it it's
hard to say what what is first and what
a second and what is the consequence of
what I mean it italy seems to be an
example that I mean the lega Nord where
she's the party chief of he is gained
the lega Nord is up in the polls I think
it's now a
a support rate of 35% of Italians this
is terrifying even even salvini is
making all these speeches maybe he's
fueling it but maybe he's just
reflecting a sentiment that isn't Italy
and Italy as you mentioned in the first
place was one of the countries that most
refugees came and from the Mediterranean
and they had a huge influx of immigrants
so this is very very complicated a
connection between what causes what
there is clearly zero phobic sentiments
inviting populism it has to be fight you
have to fight these xenophobic
anti-foreigner sentiments on the other
hand you have to reflect that there is
no consensus in the societies in Europe
about how many are migrants could be
could be come in into one country so let
me come back now to this question of
incentives and disincentives because
that in fact was in your opening
statement Anna Maria that you said we
won't combat illegal migration by
letting people die at the borders is
that in fact what you think salvini is
doing trying to dis incentivize people
to come and clearly you don't think it
works in that case irregular migration
of course I'm Tobias tonight I don't I
don't think anybody's illegal but
absolutely I mean what we should not
fall into legendas and they have a
particular agenda and they have been
using I mean colleague United States
callings in Italy as well in in
countries where they don't have that
many refugees or migrants coming it's an
agenda and we need to find a way how we
can how can we deal with the civil
society and tell them not to fall into
this agenda which is dynamize in the the
fact that migrants exist and basically
what we should be working on what we
should be doing is to kind of bring by
the dignity to migrants which we've been
using in the past three years for
political agendas so so of course he's
not right right so so the problem here
is that the more we've fallen under
discussion whether see what did the
right thing or not of course it is
there's no point out of this right I
mean but the process that is going to
continue out of here I don't think that
he is gonna stop there because I mean
they're gonna continue coming and who's
gonna be out there who's gonna
risk their there the personal liability
and and and their organizations to go
and continue rescuing for example there
is this about a German boat called
Aventa who was just released actually I
think this week after two years of being
kept by the Italian government so they
couldn't go out to operate in the
Mediterranean Sea for two years and if
we would be supporting somebody should
be these organizations we're actually
doing the most decent act of humanity
pronounced one thing I mean if you look
it's not just Italy from Finland to
Greece from the Netherlands to Denmark
to France and all these countries there
had been a a backlash after 2015 backers
from from government saying and they
took over the the rhetoric of the
right-wing populism we need to secure
our borders we need stricter policies
and so on and so on because the pressure
from all the societies were just growing
on these governments so then do you have
any sympathy for Italy's position hasn't
the EU in many ways let Italy bear the
brunt of the refugee crisis at least in
the Mediterranean yeah I mean there's
two important points that I that I think
are worth making in this debate first is
I don't think this is a crisis of
refugee numbers this is a crisis of
refugee accommodation and refugee policy
this is why we experienced the backlash
after 2015 because the EU hasn't been
able to practice real solidarity and
provide an infrastructure that helps
countries stem the influx of migrants I
don't think it's Americans themselves
we'd have to take a hard look not at
securing our borders and making sure
fewer migrants come we have to take a
hard look at European solidarity and how
we will manage refugee influxes in the
future because this is not a story that
is over now this is going to be
something that we will deal with in the
future as well and if we just close our
eyes and say okay once if we keep the
refugees outside of European borders
then our problem is solved this is not
the case and the second point I want to
make is this idea of this symbolic
discussion about saving refugees from
the Mediterranean and and this is why
we're incentivizing them this is closing
our eyes towards the real issues that
drive migration the real push factors
it's not the push factor or the pull
factor if we save people in the
Mediterranean the real push factors are
economic our security our climate change
our technological progress and if we
keep having those placeholder debates
about a few boats saving lives which is
a humanitarian imperative which you've
said we stop talking about the real
issues and this is what we have to fight
we have to push these these placeholder
debates away and start talking about the
real push and pull factors and this is
not what we do with this a sea watch
debate so essentially a saline is saying
this is very much about the fact that
once refugees do arrive in Europe or in
the United States we are not doing
enough as you said to accommodate them
to integrate them to process their their
asylum applications and so on
interestingly enough mounted that
actually was a point that was made by
Savini in relation to the Sofia
missions Sofia is a naval mission of the
EU I think in operation since 2015 the
idea was to try to stop human smuggling
in the Mediterranean particularly coming
out of Libya but elsewhere as well
salvini has complained that the mission
has turned into essentially a refugee
rescue mission in which the refugees are
then simply deposited on Italian
territory rather than being distributed
across the EU in accordance with
existing EU law doesn't he have a point
I think it's a fear of rescued 44,000
people in the Mediterranean and and as I
said the humanitarian imperative is
always so strong you say you have to
rescue these people on the other hand I
already described what I would call the
dilemma
the more you rescue the more people feel
they will be rescued there there is I
mean there clearly they are all and
they're connecting themselves they all
at them there are the Mobile's and
talking about how to come to your
because that's what they want and I
don't blame them that they want to come
but it's it's it's just let how the
system works I mean I would love to have
a common European refugee policy I would
love to have under America the German
Chancellor try to have it for four years
every week every month every day she was
saying we need that we need a fair quota
system and so on so on and she couldn't
get it because Europe is not united in
refugee policy so this is yes you're
right we need one but we don't have one
the discussion about incentives and
disincentives has played a very big role
in the u.s. debate as well so let's now
turn to the situation on the southern
border of the United States and take a
look at at the problems there refugees
are drowning there as well as here as a
recent photo show two very powerful
effect this image has circulated around
the world Oscar Ramirez and his nearly
two year-old daughter Angie valaria were
trying to flee when they drowned in the
border River Rio Grande they came from
El Salvador heading for the United
States but like so many others they
didn't make it
at home in El Salvador Oscar's mother
Rosa Ramirez clings to belongings and
photos of her son and granddaughter the
last thing he said to me on Saturday was
mama I love you they are don't worry
we're fine we then think that was his
last message when the lady isn't inside
but even if the father and daughter had
crossed the river things wouldn't have
been easy for them in America under
Donald Trump
order police and right-wing militia are
hunting down immigrants from Latin
America like never before tens of
thousands of them are being held in US
prisons and camps men women and children
hardly anyone is allowed to stay these
are people these are animals and we're
taking them out of the country at a
level at a rate that's never happened
before
it's the American dream no longer for
everyone annamaria Donald Trump has long
been talking about a crisis at the
southern border and in fact the recent
numbers appear to be barring him out why
are we seeing what is truly an enormous
tide of people coming across that border
and what is prompting acts of such
desperation as Oscar Ramirez trying to
swim with his toddler daughter nobody
would put their son or their daughter in
the water if the land would be more
dangerous you know so let's let's not
forget that Central America especially
the northern triangle has a history with
the United States over decades even the
last century but recently we cannot
forget that by the end of last year we
saw this Caravan you know people coming
together from the north northern
triangle because the journey the the
road was very dangerous for many of them
who were fleeing out ever since 2012 we
saw a real peak an increase of of
migrants particularly among component
minors so this is the time that the
caravan they organized themselves
together because the road is very
dangerous
surely crossing crossing Mexico they're
having a lot of deals and now right now
the electron is trying to basically push
Mexico to deal with the whole with the
whole situation
in fact yesterday a federal court ruled
that it is unconstitutional for donut
shop to keep these people in detention
centers without a hearing because what
so now we can say that what Donald Trump
is doing is unconstitutional just tell
us very briefly what the conditions are
like in those detention centers there
was a lot of there was a big headline
recently about the fact that young
children were being held without access
to soap and toothpaste conditions have
been called inhumane what is the problem
they are why are border authorities
unable to provide humane care yeah oh I
mean let's not forget that these people
are fleeing out from violence drug
cartels and poverty and and when they
arrive to the border especially many of
them since last year in November with a
car event their children were separated
from their parents so they're still
there together we there is a number
around 2,300 children who many of them
are alone and that already besides it's
unconstitutional before they they're
asylum seeker processes is going but
it's completely deplorable to have that
many people concentrating in very even
spaces which is not even not even for
them on top of that they're alone and
nobody's taking care of them so that
already by flip by by itself it's
already it's already wrong so then is it
a is it a funding issue or is it perhaps
again an issue of attempting to deter
migration by showing people that
conditions are abysmal Donald Trump has
said something of that nature would you
ascribe that motivation to the entire US
government I think there's there's a
combination of again a management crisis
and an inability to prepare for things
that they themselves have been warning
about for months but we see parallels
with European policy as well right so we
see Donald Trump threatening Mexico with
tariffs what Germany is doing or what
the EU is doing is traveling around
Africa
offering development assistance to curb
migration right we extend the number of
safe third countries in Europe and Trump
wants to make a deal with Mexico as a
treaty of an immigration security treaty
to treat Mexico as the country sort of a
Dublin system where they have to claim
asylum in Mexico themselves so there's a
lot of parallels not onl only in the
imagery that you showed before but also
in the policy level but surely it is not
forced to give development assistance to
try to help people in the countries
where they live so the question is why
do we give development assistance right
do we give it to actually foster
economic growth in those countries or is
it sort of a financial incentive to
decrease migration but it is a funding
issue because there is there is
obviously in this in the Centers there
needs to be there needs to be a better
better conditions but what we have to do
is to basically call the Congress to
monitor what is happening with that
money because that money is not arriving
for the people who are in the sanction
centers not to looming one sentence let
me take us back to our title trust
refugees rescue forbidden do you think
we will see this system change anytime
soon no it's a very very short answer
but I can't see I can't see a consensus
in the European Union I can't see a
consensus in the United States even
though the Democratic Party is not an
open border party as well because they
even support it for billions of money to
secure the borders they're gonna have to
cut you off right there thank you all
for being with us thanks to all of you
out there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]